[Musique]
les fêtes sont derrière nous les excès
aussi place aux résolutions
si les régimes minceur ont la cote des
mises en garde s'impose la volonté de
blanc perdre quelques lits il a fait
partie des résolutions mais je devrai
une des obsessions
ben je pense que notre société est
obsédé par la perte de poids à l'année
au delà des habitudes de vie
scientifiquement non quand on regarde
les études on devrait s'intéresser à au
changement de notre mode de vie pour
apporter des bienfaits notre santé
globale jusque le dire plus que la perte
de poids pour qu'on s'en fout mais que
ça devrait pas faire source de
motivation première est d'ordre est
notre santé ça devrait des changements
concrets à tous les niveaux de notre de
nos habitudes de vie ça peut être qu'au
niveau du sommeil vous la gestion du
stress qui ont rien à voir avec la perte
de poids mais qui vont avoir un effet
majeur sur la santé globale et une ses
côtés sociale parce que oui la paire de
bottes et une obsession qu'on a dans
notre société mais l'acte de manger
d'abord et avant tout c'est un acte
social et culturel oui c'est un moment
de partage
absolument c'est tellement important ne
serait ce que pour avoir du plaisir
pardon une relation saine avec les
aliments qui partager ce moment là en
famille entre amis
alors que certains médias qui vont un
peu à contre-courant là où succès
d'avoir des moments de partage de
rassemblement avec une z story
mais la diète étage est un bon exemple a
dit aux jeunes c'est surtout composée de
gras donc 72% donc à leur vie
énergie dans la journée va provenir des
lipides 20 portant des protéines ce qui
ressemble à une demande normale de
l'alimentation normale et seulement 10%
maximum de notre énergie sous forme de
lucide pour ne pas dépasser ça pour
mettre notre corps c'est aux donc là on
va aller chercher l'énergie dans les
grottes plutôt que dans les glucides
on doit évidemment illuminé le pain les
pâtes elle plusieurs fruits certains
légumes comme les légumes nationaux ce
qu'on va le suivre
oui lol et les bananes fauté mais ça
fait quand même plaisir certaines
personnes parce que les aliments plus
riches comme le fromage la crème sa ccc
permis c à volonté presque
donc c'est accrocheur dans ce sens là et
comme la plupart des diètes faible très
faible en glucides s'entraînent une
perte de poids rapide
après est-ce que ça dure dans le temps
sont le sport et surtout c'est quoi les
effets néfastes potentiels à long terme
ce non plus on le sait pas on eu très
peu de films donc on peut parler de la
constipation peut aussi parler du
microbiote donc les bactéries qui sont
dans nos intestins se nourrissent des
fibres qu'on consomme donc le des gens
d'un équilibre qu'est ce que ça fait à
long terme principe on ne sait pas non
plus au niveau des problèmes rénaux
au niveau de l'ostéoporose parce que
l'état de ses troupes dans notre corps
est en cette hausse il ya une grande
expression tir de calcium dans les os
donc sauf ça fait quoi à long terme on
ne sait pas non plus en fait c'est une
bonne question de deux bonnes questions
à se poser si on entrevoit commencer une
vieille pour le début d'année est ce que
je pourrai manger comme ça pour le
restant de mes jours
sinon c'était une bonne idée autre chose
est ce que ça va faire en sorte que je
vais m'isoler de ma famille de mes amis
parce que je mange complètement
différemment qu'il faut faire deux repas
où l'on mange juste eu avec sa famille
ou ses amis parce que c'est trop
compliqué c'est trop compliqué c'est
probablement pas durable